you know one of the um traps that
i will sometimes fall into and i know
that that many of my friends do as well
and
people i follow on twitter is this idea
that
okay this is over the line no one is
actually
going to find a way to defend this and
every single time we are disappointed or
is it surprised or let down or whatever
the case may be
and this applies to the insurrectionist
mob of rioters that donald trump incited
yesterday
who went to the u.s capitol breached
security breached the doors broke
windows got into nancy pelosi's office
and vandalized and so on and so forth
and i i sort of jokingly what's a joke
these days
i sort of uh tongue-in-cheek suggested
i'm sure they'll figure out a way to
blame antifun black lives matter for
this
and that's exactly what many people did
uh here is a clip from um
so this is happening at the high level
and it's happening at the low level
for a clip at the high level when last
night
the vote resumed in the joint session
most networks were covering it but on
fox news
laura ingram was saying
that she heard that
from the washington times there were at
least two antifa
spotted in the crowd i'm not kidding
take a look actions we saw today
do not represent this movement the
washington times is reporting
that at least two and tifa were spotted
in the crowd
so listen first of all
uh even if it were true that there were
two antifa
spotted there were thousands of violent
trump insurrectionists pushing their way
onto the capital portico
and some of them into the building etc
etc so
even if it were true that two antifa
were spotted it wouldn't really tell us
much about the reality of what took
place yesterday it was a
incited by trump pro-trump
trumpist riotous seditious insurrection
period but what does it mean to antifa
were spotted
did they have signs because if they were
just dressed in black
a lot of the riotous pro-trump
seditionists were also dressed in black
and they specifically many of them
planned to dress in black so
what if this is true it's irrelevant
whether it's true is a real question and
then of course
the idea that this is anything other
than a
genuine pro-trump movement is not
supported by fact now unfortunately
so ingram is an example of this
happening at the high level oh it's two
antifa were spotted
absolute trash okay but friends of mine
who have conservative family members as
an example
i had an inbox full of screenshots
and and uh posts yesterday of
my friend's aunt my friend's cousin
whoever else
posting all sorts of content
claiming that this entire thing was
staged
by the left there really weren't any
trumpets that
the trumpets that were there and
peacefully walked to the capitol
weren't the same ones that breached and
uh of course you have to suspend all
disbelief
in order to to even plausibly consider
that this is the case
but unfortunately once again when we
assume
wrongly this is over the line nobody
will defend this even for them this is
too much
we're wrong every single time and they
figured out a way
through a combination of arguing that a
few bad apples maybe not even right
wingers they might the bad apples might
all have been antifa or black lives
matter for which there is no evidence
another version that i saw and in fact
there are some enlightened centrists who
have youtube channels who were making
this case
the problem is the media with bloodlust
showing the video of what's going on i
actually heard that yesterday and saw it
on twitter today which is
the the problem is not the first order
which
is that people are doing this and they
are trumpists and even though we were
told it's the left that's violent it's
the right that has done
something that hasn't happened since the
19th century breaching the capital uh
building with
with property crime and vandalism and
violence and all this stuff
that's really the issue there were
people saying the
the media's coverage of this is uh
sensational and salacious
the what what that's that's what you
think is the problem the fact that media
were
accurately reporting about the seditious
insurrectionist riotous behavior that
was taking place
so we've seen every combination there is
no defense
too absurd there is no defense too
ridiculous that some of them won't try
it
you know there's all these rules god
wins law which i think is
the longer an internet discussion goes
on the more likely it becomes someone
makes an analogy to hitler or nazis or
you know all the occam's razor there
should be some principle named
uh for the idea that any defense
of trump or trumpists no matter how
absurd
will eventually be made and put out
there
uh by by some of these trumpists and
all we can really do is continue
to stick to the facts uh not
become overly you know one of the things
was a lot of people were writing to me
saying how do i respond to this you know
my aunt is posting
that what's going on is not really
what's going on what what do i do and my
my advice is do nothing
unfortunately my i think that if you
want to adopt what i call a retail
strategy which is arguing with people
one-on-one
i don't really have advice for you i i
really don't i don't think it's a good
idea
if some if somebody really sees what
happened yesterday and actually
believes or has convinced themselves
that they believe it was really antifa
or something like that
i don't see the point of arguing with
them i think the the healthier approach
is to say
um this person believes this stuff as a
result of like a 40-year campaign
of pseudo and anti-intellectualism and
and false
talking points that really go back to
like reagan's idea of this welfare queen
who was just getting rich off of having
kids and drove a cadillac and and live
this great life
that is sort of the beginning of
everything we've seen immigrants are the
are dangerous
and communists are coming in and social
joe biden's association you know all
that stuff
we need to be thinking about about more
of a wholesale strategy
which includes changing the media
landscape
changing the culture changing education
and i my
instinct is that's healthier than
getting frustrated with aunt blanche
uh sharing that crazy thing about how it
was really antifa who did the thing it
to me it seems like an exercise in in
futility
uh but i'm open to having my mind change
that that's just my advice
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in
cherry ice flavor lucy is affordable
it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store shipping is always free
you can buy single boxes or save with a
subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away and get rid of the
vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just
a quick disclaimer i'm required to give
these products contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical